I think something it's amazingly cool
about you is after blossom you went back
to school for your PhD what did you get
your PhD in I got my PhD and in
neuroscience from UCLA and Wow yes thank
you I like to say besides getting you
apart on the Big Bang Theory
I was also made these folks Merced the
spokesperson of Texas Instruments
calculators so that's what you get with
a PhD in neuroscience Big Bang Theory
and you're the spokesperson for graphing
calculators i I do applaud that I love
the idea that you decided no I want to
go out and get a serious education and I
also know that big bang that is a show
that it's very serious about getting the
facts right when they talk about science
they want the facts to be right even
though I'm watching it it could be
anything you know I'm like a cat I'm
just they could write anything on the
board would you do you actually help
them keep the facts straight as a
neuroscientist um you know when I
auditioned for the part I on my resume
under miscellaneous
it says PhD neuroscience cuz I didn't
know where else to put it on an acting
resume so I did it under miscellaneous
and Bill Brady or most people put
juggling I didn't speak Hebrew Spanish
PhD in neuroscience Wow and Bill Prady
our creator executive producer at the
audition said is this for real I said
yeah it kind of is I have a PhD so when
they brought me back for the fourth
season he said they figured why not make
her what I am so that I can you know fix
small things if they're wrong but
generally they get pretty much
everything right so I talked to my
writers about like oh yeah I'm not sure
that was the funniest way to go you
correct them on no that's not the region
of the brain that does that
I love that doctor could you explain my
children to me when they make those
plans are they what is that about isn't
it the boy the the young males frontal
lobe er is reasoning executive
functional Harris control yes don't
girls get it get it at 14 or 15 they can
think and boys not till 22 or is that is
that why there is something that's what
I'm experienced well there is a there is
a theory that there was a theory that
boys never get it we never actually
experienced that's why they do crazy
things
well there's variation in the
development of the frontal lobe and that
is some impulse control girls get it
faster statistically speaking yes yeah
cuz I'm seeing that go ahead I believe
can you ask the doctor a question Andy
next question doctor neuroscience all
the time this is very exciting you play
it you to you you to have something in
common which is you played a role when
you were a child before blossom you
played a role that helped prepare you
for the Big Bang right I did I did a
role when I was 11 years old I had just
started acting and I did you know I was
a character actress you know this this
face on an 11 year old date gets
character roles
I did eight episodes I did eight
episodes of Webster and I played this
this super nerd called Frieda and I
based it on the church lady and I
brought a picture really have you
actually tried yeah I think we have a
split screen here of there
[Applause]
[Music]
you're adorable
[Applause]